what are you even watching Kona
um so I finished chainsaw man which is
great yeah there's not really much to
say other than can I have more please
yep wow that's pretty much we are
getting some more yeah I know I mean
it's like yeah it's [__] amazing and
yeah it's good and you should watch it
and it's worth the hype and uh yeah
don't don't be a don't do what Joey does
sometimes and just be like it's too
popular to be fair I did watching okay
even even even even Joey couldn't
couldn't even Joey couldn't resist that
he couldn't resist it was coded as a
Fujimoto fan I had to all right uh I
watched four episodes of blue lock oh
yeah and then I'm done I think I'm out
really I think it's just it's too boring
it's really so [__] oh you think blue
looks sure I really enjoyed it yeah why
do you think it was [__] oh my god
um was it the sports element or I kind
of wish people would just die that would
be much better if people just died when
they got kicked out and make it way more
interesting so you want squid game
basically I just figured if they didn't
go that's a completely different [__]
TV series
watch blue lock right and tell me if
they didn't change it so that they died
that the characters would act any
different they would be the exact same
the characters pretend like they're
literally about to die anyway if they
don't score this goal or if they don't
like win this thing so I'm like just
[__] kill them well is that some
[__] stage I don't think not playing
for the Japanese team is that bad okay
sue me why is he acting like a lion's
Crush but that's the thing all these
characters in blue log that is their
life of like the wanting to get to that
team so then that is the life and death
that's the whole point of every Sports
Anime is that every Sports anime
character don't have a life outside of
that yeah exactly like I think ping pong
is like the one exception
I'm tired of it I watched it I'm like oh
great these are four characters that I
could say that they copy pasted from
like five like half the characters feel
like they're like copy paste from
yomushu pedal like there's so many other
characters in it as well that feel like
I'm watching like an amalgamation of
crocono basket and then yomoshu pedal
and other sports anime just
conglomerates
so why don't you care if other sports
anime characters no no I think I'm just
done I think I'm done with Sports Anime
and I think this is okay okay that's
that's fine because I I like blue log
just because you know no one dies in it
as no one really does in Sports Anime
you know I don't really go into Sports
Anime thinking people are gonna die I
like blue lock because all most Sports
Anime is about oh guys let's let's all
play together let's win with the power
of friendship and teamwork and blue
looks like [__] that [__] you go out in
there to be selfish yeah and be like
egotistical yeah [__] together that's
what pissed me off is that they they did
this and they pushed this and then
they're like okay now players are team
and then you're like what and then now
they have to figure out no but then but
then that's the that creates an
interesting Dynamic of a bunch of people
who are trying to kick each other off
while also trying to work as a team so
that Dynamic is interesting but It
ultimately just came down to like okay
this is the cash uh this is gonna be the
team and they're gonna learn to work
together and by the way uh that's the
show is not about that and it's about
not working together and being the
person who does all the work I just got
pissed off I was like it just feels like
there's so many contradictions and and
then not to be that guy but oh my God
whenever they had 3G 3D shots I was like
what the [__] is that that [__] was
hideous well don't tell me that okay
everyone's trying to shoot up and change
someone for the 3D dude but blue lock
had some ass 3D well I I also don't want
to be that guy but the market was better
of course the manga was better I'm
watching this show and I'm like holy
[__] the pacing sucks ass you know
that's true though with bluelock the
manga is better it is I can already like
I I ran ahead I'm literally sitting next
to anime Twitter like literally
no no
no no okay because what happened was is
that there was so much other [__] I
didn't like yeah then now I won't make
excuses in my head for the [__] 3D right
like if it was good I would ignore the
3D but when they do those overhead shots
where they pass the ball and everyone's
just static and like their shitty 3D
models I'm like this is show ass I can't
do this and like I would not even think
it was that bad being honest I don't
ever remember I think I was just pissed
off from how annoyed I was at the story
that it made me more angry and like I I
just hated it I just thought it was all
right because like I liked the part I
liked about blue lock was that they
didn't kill them because I'm so [__]
because I'm so [__] sick of these
like death game [__] animes that have
like I mean it's like oh guys I mean
they did oh my God they killed somebody
I do want to say that it's just me being
like [__] dumb no I get it I just
think that like I just man it felt so
slow as well like it felt like nothing
happened really all the time yeah I felt
like four episodes yeah it felt like
barely anything had happened that's
really fun because I think in terms of
like normal Sports Anime pacing blue
lock is really fast paced compared to a
lot of sports around me yeah like
especially the first four episodes of
blue lock I [__] enjoyed the [__] out
of blue lock uh Adam and I am enjoying
the [__] out of blue lock uh just
because it's just a different take on
Sports Anime I think it's a lot fun
maybe you're just done with Sports Anime
because yeah I mean I'm done with I just
think the whole
the whole way it's done is kind of lame
uh yeah I mean I'm like
not my like I've I did realize something
after watching blue lock and another
football anime this year owl uh our ashy
which is like a production IG Sports
Anime about football
um which is like more traditional Sports
style I realize [__]
I I think I just enjoyed watching real
sport now because God [__] damn going
from watching blue log to watching the
World Cup I was like this is so much
better what why am I watching sports
anime what I could be watching the
[__] World Cup you're seeing Japan's
Ark in the World Cup seeing the [__]
that happened in Japan as much as her
that was way more excited than anything
that happened in the World Cup
four more years yeah we just got to wait
for them you know [__] I think also uh
what really uh I don't know why this
kind of turned me off so much when they
all started [__] talking about how
they have like a in blue lock right so
it's football but some of the characters
have just monsters inside of them and
I'm like nah nah I'm done I'm like
that's I'm I'm like this [__] I like
that
it's uh it's schizophrenia actually yeah
yeah it's like it's like oh why did you
pass me the monster told me I'm like
shut the [__] up can you not just be
good at the [__] sport why do you
have to have some schizophrenic tendency
for you to be remotely even interesting
as a character like why do why it needs
to be that or some kind of like [__]
superpower okay like why why for me to
care about a character do you have to be
schizophrenic and have funny hair like I
just I just come on like there's got to
be better ways to write these characters
so I'm saying man that's why slam dunk
is the goat and they don't have any of
that yeah and then like the second the
fourth episode the one I kind of clocked
out they were like against this team I
don't know why it pissed me off this
main character should hentai hair and I
was like I'm just why I'm just I don't
know why it's pissed me off I'm like
it's just a [__] he has a [__]
hentai protagonist right now this guy
was done NTR in five minutes ago
I'm like I'm like I don't know why I'm
just I'm just this shows I can't keep
watching this I'm done you just you just
see [__] messy like all the top
football players they're just like [__]
they're just schizophrenic you know and
Bobby in the World Cup final he was just
listening to his little monster that was
telling him to
and you just see the [__] uh like the
sketchy eyes they get when they're
listening to their monsters what's up
with that the one thing I did like is
that they were like the reason we're
[__] as a nation is because we're not
selfish all right guys so we need more
selfishness from you guys all right so
can we can we make a center to Harbor
selfishness so when I heard that I was
like bars yeah
we just guys we're just not selfish
enough let's make a multi-million dollar
facility to make uh kids more selfish uh
so that's what we're gonna do uh that's
all in favor say aye and the only way we
can do that is to pit you all against
each other
I don't know I think blue locks just
dumb fun it's it's I'm never gonna take
it seriously oh no I wish I wish I wish
I could look at it like that but I think
I'm just burnt out on Sports Anime